was ist da los fragt ihr euch vielleicht
auch nach dem schockurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts fehlen dem
Bund plötzlich viele Milliarden das
Bundesfinanzministerium verhängt für
fast den gesamten Bundeshaushalt eine
Haushaltssperre das gab's noch nie und
die entscheidende Sitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses für den Haushalt
2024 die wurde erstmal abgesagt damit
bricht der fein austarierte Zeitplan für
den nächsten Haushalt erstmal
auseinander was heißt das sind wir jetzt
pleite müssen wie in den USA das immer
mal wieder passiert jetzt auch bei uns
Regierungsbehörden bald ihre Arbeit
einstellen bis wieder Geld da ist vor
allem was wird eigentlich aus den Zielen
der Ampel also den Investitionen in den
Klimaschutz digitales und die Bahn oder
den Ausbau der Elektromobilität all das
kostet ja richtig viel Geld bedeutet das
karlsra Urteil dass wir uns eine
funktionierende Infrastruktur oder eine
pünktliche Bahn und vieles mehr erstmal
abschminken können ich bin Thomas
reicher Korrespondent im ZF
hauptstadstudio und ich erkläre euch
warum die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts eine
Katastrophe ist und uns am Ende doch
helfen
[Applaus]
könnte das Urteil aus Karlsruhe war ein
Schock für die Ampel im Hintergrund
Räumen hohe ampelianer ein dass sie fest
davon ausgingen das passt schon der
Klima und transformationsfond so etwas
wie die große fette Spardose für den
Umbau des Industrielandes Deutschland
hin zu mehr Klimaschutz dieser KTF ist
schon verfassungskonform das sagten die
eigenen Juristen und die wurden
höchstens nach der mündlichen
Verhandlung im Juni in CHS R ein
bisschen unruhig aber dass es soweit
kommt zunächst reagiert die Ampel darauf
mit einer Art von nicht wahrhaben wollen
für uns ist ganz klar dass das jetzt
eine Sache ist die wir auch gerne mit
dem Parlament erörtern und deshalb freue
ich mich dass genau heute die Befragung
des Kanzlers im Bundestag gleich beginnt
langsam aber dämmert allen das wre
Ausmaß des schlammassels hart trifft es
vor allem Robert habbeck die 60
Milliarden aus dem KTF hat er eigentlich
fest verplant für den Ausbau von
klimaneutralen Heizungen dem Ausbau der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft oder um
Chipfabriken in Deutschland anzusiedeln
schon im Sommer zeichnet habbeck ein
düsteres Bild was passiert wenn das Geld
nicht da ist wenn diese Klage
erfolgreich ist das würde Deutschland
wirklich wirtschaftspolitisch hart hart
treffen wahrscheinlich so hart dass wir
das nicht bestehen werden und wird es
jetzt wirklich so schlimm zieht es nicht
nur der Ampel sondern uns allen damit
den Boden oder den Füßen
[Musik]
weg 60 Milliarden fehlen wenn es nur das
wäre hätten wir jetzt keine
Haushaltssperre das Problem ist
tatsächlich größer viel größer denn das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
sagt der Staat darf sich nicht quasi auf
Vorrat für die nächsten Jahre
Verschulden er darf nicht neue Projekte
mit alten Krediten bezahlen aber genau
das ist das Prinzip noch eines anderen
Fonds des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds des WSF
wenn ihr den nicht kennt dann aber
vermutlich die etwas großpurige Art mit
der er damals angekündigt wurde man kann
sagen dass es hier ein doppelwums es
soll dazu beitragen dass jetzt schnell
zügig und für alle schnell feststellar
die Preise sinken für Energie so dass
sich niemand Sorgen machen muss wenn er
an den Herbst und den Winter denkt wenn
er an Weihnachten denkt und dann das
nächste Jahr und an die Rechnung das
Finanzministerium geht jedenfalls davon
aus dass auch der WSF verfassungswidrig
ist und hat weitere sogenannte
ausgabeverpflichtungen daraus erstmal
gesperrt was bedeutet das für die Ampel
erstmal ist es für sie ein riesenprem
der KTF war der große Kit für die
Koalition er sorgte dafür dass die SPD
soziales versprechen konnte wie den
Mindestlohn von 12 € grüne mehr
Klimaschutz und die FDP trotzdem sagen
konnte die Schuldenbremse die wird
eingehalten es fehlt jetzt einfach
wahnsinnig viel Geld zunächst mal für
den Haushalt von habbeck also Klima
grüne Kernanliegen die Grünen aber haben
schon mal klar gemacht das alles ist
nicht allein unser Problem und zwar
unisono wer glaubt es ging jetzt nur um
die Grünen und wir hätten Problem dann
irren Sie schränkt erst mal auch die
Länder ein es schränkt den Bund ein es
schränkt auch die jetzige
Oppositionspartei im Bundestag ein man
muss sich dar Klaren sind dass da
insbesondere um Projekte geht der
Transformation der Industrie deswegen
ist es mindestens so ein Problem für die
SPD wird die Ampel daran zerbrechen
wahrscheinlich nicht bei der Wahl würden
alle drei verlieren die SPD vermutlich
die Kanzlerschaft die FDP ihren Platz im
Bundestag und auch die Grünen die
vielleicht noch am wenigsten aber auch
bei ihnen gilt der Zuspruch den sie
zunächst in der Ampel erfuhren der ist
verdampft spbd und FDP aber traf es noch
übler wenn man sich die Umfragen
anschaut stehen wir von Seiten der
ampelparteien noch mit Abstand im
Vergleich zum Wahlergebnis am besten da
das hilft do jetzt nichts zu sagen die
Umfrageergebnisse sind gar nicht so
schlecht es hilft schon was nämlich wenn
die Umfrageergebnisse noch schlechter
werden das sehen Sie gerade bei anderen
Parteien ist die Lage noch mal eine ganz
andere die Union hat gegen den KTF
geklagt aber auch sie hat jetzt ein
Problem in der Fraktionssitzung nach dem
Urteil soll Wolfgang Schäuble die
Unionisten gewarnt haben so berichtet es
jedenfalls der Spiegel eines sagte
schäubele müsse man im Auge behalten das
Urteil werde die Spielräume für künftige
Regierungen massiv einschränken auch
wenn sie von der Union geführt würden
Schu kennt sich aus oder der weiß
vermutlich die Union trägt
Mitverantwortung weil sie in ihrer
Regierungszeit Probleme liegen gelassen
und zu wenig investiert hat siehe die
lange und wenig ruhmreiche Reihe der CSU
Verkehrsminister die die Bahn
vernachlässigt haben was bedeutet das
jetzt für uns für den Klimaschutz für
den Ausbau des digitalen und die
Ansiedlung von Chipfabriken für die
Modernisierung der Bahn wie kommen wir
da wieder
[Musik]
raus erstmal vielleicht die gute
Nachricht wir sind nicht Pleite es
werden auch keine Regierungsbehörden
schließen wie in Amerika aber in der
aktuellen Notlage braucht es womöglich
erstmal einen großen feuerlöscheer und
der hieße Schulden machen um die
weggebrochenen Schulden auszugleichen
Deutschland kann sich das leisten der
Schuldenstand ist im Vergleich zu
anderen Ländern noch vergleichsweise
niedrig vielleicht wegen der
Schuldenbremse um das zu machen müsste
der Bund erneut eine Haushaltsnotlage
beschließen für dieses Jahr damit werend
dann zumindest Zahlungen aus dem WSF zur
energiepreisbremse abgesichert die bis
Oktober schon geflossen sind das sind
etwa 37 Milliarden Euro von denen im
Moment noch niemand weiß woher die sonst
kommen sollen und dann Schuldenbremse
aufheben dafür bräucht es die Stimmen
der FDP die strickt dagegen ist die
Schuldenbremse reformieren also die
Spielräume erweitern damit der Staat
mehr investieren kann dafür bräucht es
zusätzlich die Stimmen der Union im
Moment also eher nein aber der Druck auf
März und könnte wachsen dass die Union
an so einer Lösung am Ende doch mitwirkt
höhere Steuern mehr sparen schon möglich
dass der Druck des karlsrau Urteils
genau dazu führt dass die Ampel sich auf
beides einigt das muss nicht so schlecht
sein eine höhere Erbschaftssteuer oder
eine Vermögenssteuer z.B oder sparen bei
bestimmten Subventionen wie dem
Dienstwagenprivileg aber reichen wird
das vermutlich
[Musik]
nicht es könnte sein dass am Ende ess
wieder auf Karlsruhe ankommt auf ein
anderes bahnbrechendes Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts im april 2021
entschiedes dass es ein Grundrecht auf
Zukunft für nachfolgende Generationen
gebe und sagte damit auch Klimaschutz
hat verfassungsrah der Bundestag hat
daraufhin das Klimaschutzgesetz
entsprechend geändert Deutschland soll
bis
2045 klimaneutral werden dafür braucht
es eben erhebliche Investitionen der
Bundestag könnte also beschließen den
Klima und transformationsfonds den KTF
nun wirklich auf die richtigen Beine zu
stellen und ihn mit zwei Drittel
Mehrheit als Sondervermögen ausstatten
so ähnlich wie beim Sondervermögen der
Bundeswehr dazu müsste natürlich die
Union mitmachen aber warum eigentlich
nicht das Klimaschutzgesetz stammt aus
den letzten Tagen der großen Koalition
als die Union noch in der Regierung war
könnte also eine Lösung sein die am Ende
auch wieder aus chaosruhe kommt aber was
meint ihr wie viel Schulden soll und
darf der Stadt machen für Investitionen
ins Klima dafür dass unser Land moderner
wird schreibt es uns wir sind sehr
gespannt darauf und wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann abonniert diesen Kanal
auf
Wiedersehen